my name is avi euro Golu and I'm an
assistant professor in the economics
group at stanford graduate school of
business in the united states in the
last couple years there's been a rapid
increase in the number of certain class
of pharmaceuticals that are considered
under shortage the exact area
pharmaceuticals where this has been
happening is sterile injectable
pharmaceuticals these are in drugs that
are injected into your body for your
bloodstream so mostly done at the
hospital at doctor's office like
chemotherapies anaesthesia these are
medicines that are not that expensive
these are generic medicines so it should
be getting produced people have
traditionally had access to them and
there's been an increase in the number
of plant shutdowns and the number of
drugs that have been taken off the
market the last couple of years it's
become a bit of a public health crisis
there's a debate about why the increase
in shortages all of a sudden is it just
bad luck increased number of people
getting sick or is there something
regulatory going on
my research focuses on a regulatory
change that occurred in 2005 for a large
proportion of the country mostly old
people and disabled the insurance
company is the government its Medicare
before 2005 they go they get their drug
their health provider doctor bills
Medicare Medicare Germans at what rate
they pay for these services before 2005
Medicare paid at what was called the
average wholesale price so they looked
at how much did it cost your hospital to
buy this drug that was the goal but
there was a loophole in this definition
there was nothing that Medicare could
actually verify how much the hospital
was paying for the drug so you ended up
with this price which was a bit of an
artificial price Medicare saw this they
realize we need to decrease healthcare
expenditures why not tie the
reimbursement rate to exactly what the
hospital's opening make that price that
they report correspond to something in
reality the question is did this
decrease in payments cause the increase
in shortages after this lag and that's
where my research comes in the basic
idea is you look at drugs would serve a
lot of Medicare patients just based on
the the class of diseases drug serve
you're going to serve older or younger
patients the change in Medicare payments
is behind the increase in shortages
drugs which are more reliant on Medicare
for the revenue should have had a
greater increase in shortages and drugs
that are less reliant I found that
indeed yes drugs which are more relying
on Medicare I've had a greater increase
in shortages after the policy teams
the way healthcare expenditures have
been growing it's going to bankrupt the
country now the question is how to do it
to do it in a smart way so this is one
example where well-intentioned effort to
decrease expenditures may have led to
unintended consequences I view this
shortage issue as sort of a microcosm
for the larger sort of million-dollar
question which is how should we reduce
healthcare expenditures without hurting
innovation in this case we reduce
expenditures and we heard something
closely related to innovation which is
investment in production the incentives
to produce and maintain capacity for a
certain drug which is very similar to
the decision to develop a new drug
there's both overuse and under use in
our healthcare systems of your under use
of preventive medicine that ends up
driving up connoisseur overuse of
medicine that doesn't really cure or or
treat diseases that drives up costs the
question is how to tailor those cuts to
decrease overuse and increase under use
and it's not an easy problem here's one
example where they've arguably got it
wrong and have dire consequences
you